ils giroux et le directeur parlementaire
du budget à ottawa bonsoir monsieur
giraud bonsoir monsieur fillion 252
milliards de dollars de déficit c'est
soixante dix milliards de plus que votre
projection d'il ya trois semaines qu'est
ce qui explique cela inquiète explique
ceci en dit la divulgation de nouvelles
données notamment sur l'emploi sur la
décroissance économique et aussi des
mesures additionnelles qui ont été
annoncées au presque à chaque jour en
fait il ya des mesures additionnelles
qui s'accumulent qui s'ajoutent aux
prévisions de dépenses ou au scénario de
dépenses qu'on fait donc c'est ce qui
explique en bonne partie que le fait que
le déficit se creuse alors presque d'une
semaine sur l'autre ces temps ci les
choses vont tellement rapidement qu'on
doit mettre à jour nos scénarios assez
régulièrement et c'est surtout l'ampleur
des mesures qui sont annoncées qui
explique le fait que le déficit se
creuse de plus en plus et 252 milliards
on n'arrête pas le curseur là ça
pourrait plus important encore oui ce
scénario là dans lequel on
enregistrerait un déficit de 252
milliards ça tient compte du fait que
les mesures de déconfinement seraient
mises en oeuvre progressivement tout au
long de l'année 2020 mais ça ne tient
pas compte de mesures de relance
économique qui vont probablement être
nécessaires
même une fois que la pandémie sera ce
sera résorbé donc si jamais des mesures
de relance économique de plusieurs
dizaines de milliards de dollars
faudrait ajouter cela au montant du
déficit donc les déficits en
probablement beaucoup plus de chances
d'augmenter
plutôt que de baisser comparativement au
scénario qu'on a divulgué ce matin chute
du pib dites-vous de 12%
est ce que est ce qu on comprend que la
chute économique et plus grande moins
d'heures travaillées finalement au
deuxième trimestre parce que je vois que
vos chiffres pour le troisième et
quatrième trimestre le rebond sera plus
fort mais la jetée plus profonde c'est
ça et exactement donc on a accru nos
neveux l'ampleur de la chute de dollars
décroissance économique du recul du pib
lors du deuxième trimestre mais
conséquemment il y aura un rebond qui va
être un peu plus important que ce qu'on
prévoyait ou ce qu'on a anticipé plus
tôt lors de la mise à jour précédent ce
qui ce qui qui pallie en partie aux
mauvaises nouvelles d'une décélération
beaucoup plus rapide qu'anticipé mais
c'est un peu compréhensible si la chute
est plus rapide
on anticipe que le rebond va
probablement être aussi un peu plus
prononcée
mais qui va être loin de compenser pour
le recul du deuxième trimestre c'est
difficile d'imaginer un rebond prononcée
en même temps parce qu'on n'arrête pas
de nous dire que le retour sera
extrêmement progressif que tant qu'on
n'a pas de vaccin va falloir vivre avec
la distanciation sociale
comment on peut rebondir rapidement si
on doit fonctionner à moitié puis on
doit fonctionner au télétravail
puis qu'il ya des gens qui pourront pas
reprendre des activités normales je vous
ai malheureusement perdu pendant
quelques secondes
bon je reprendrai pas toute la question
mais puisque la transition sera l'ongle
avec des activités qui vont prendre du
temps avant de trouver un vaccin là
comment on peut assister rebond rapide
dans les circonstances on prévoit pas de
rebond rapide compris voici une chute et
une reprise graduelle de l'activité donc
à ce qu on appelle souvent une reprise
en bâtons de hockey ou ce que d'autres
appellent plus poétiquement une reprise
en u donc une baisse précipitée puis une
reprise progressive parce qu'avec un
choc économique de l'ampleur de celui
qu'on vit c'est sûr que les entreprises
qui vont malheureusement fermé leurs pas
et ça va entraîner une baisse de
confiance marques et les consommateurs
et aussi des entreprises qui va avoir
une période de transition entre le temps
où des entreprises ferme et d'autres
ouvrent leurs portes ou reprennent leur
rythme de croisière et ça va entraîner
une partie de chômage on peut pas
entrevoir une reprise en dépareillant
dans cet asile assez constante
croissance si je me trompe pas au
quatrième trimestre oui mais c'est pas
sur une base annuelle c'est sur une base
trimestre
rimmel week-end les mesures annoncées
une fois qu'elles seront retirés
est ce qu'on comprend que le déficit là
qui est énorme en ce moment va revenir à
quelque chose de plus normal mais il va
certainement revenir à quelque chose de
moins gigantesques mais la baisse des
revenus contribuent pour une bonne
partie à creuser le déficit dans notre
scénario divulgué ce matin donc entre 60
et 70 milliards de dollars du déficit
qui est due uniquement la baisse des
revenus
donc même si on suppose que toutes les
mesures de soutien expire tel que prévu
donc elles ne sont pas prolongées on
serait quand même face à un déficit qui
friserait le 100 milliards de dollars ce
qui est considérable est ce que dans les
circonstances et avec la dette qui va
augmenter beaucoup là vous le faites
passer de 30 à 40 8% à peu près du
produit intérieur brut
est ce que dans les circonstances vous
pensez que la note parfaite de très plat
du canada pourrait commencer à être
questionné c'est possible qu'elle
commence à être questionné ce qui va
être important pour garder cette bonne
cote de crédit là c'est d'avoir un plan
de relance concret et crédible mais
aussi un plan de contrôle du déficit qui
vont aussi être réduit donc si le
gouvernement continue à dépenser pour
relancer l'économie mais qui au pod de
ya pas de l'impression que le
gouvernement veut vraiment mieux
contrôler son déficit une fois la crise
passée
donc les cris que les agences de crédit
vont peut-être commencé à questionner
cependant si le gouvernement instaure
clairement un plan de réduction du
déficit ou encore si la croissance
économique est très fort c'est possible
que la cote de crédit du canada se
maintiennent
cela étant dit faut considérer ce qui ce
qui se passe ailleurs dans les autres
pays la plupart des pays font face aux
exactement au même moment guy fille à la
même crise évidemment et ont tous
engagés les dépenses très importantes
donc comparativement aux autres pays on
se trouve en relative bonne posture
dernière question est ce que les mesures
qui ont été adoptées de tout un débat
dans la société nuisent à l'incitation
au travail
ça c'est un débat vraiment délicat le
gouvernement a instauré ces mesures là
de façon rapide pour donner de l'aide
aux gens qui en avaient besoin puis
aucun doute que des centaines de
milliers de personnes qui ont besoin
d'être quand leur entreprise ou leur
employeur les licencie cela étant dit
lorsque la reprise hausse amorcée on
voit déjà des anecdotes ou des gens
refusent de travailler ou préfèrent ne
pas retourner tout de suite au travail
parce que ils ont une pompe de soutien
au revenu et ça c'est clair n'importe
qui qui qui extraient face à ce choix là
on retourne travailler au salaire
minimum ou d'un salaire qui est prêt ou
on on se fait ouvrir 500 $ par semaine
pour ne pas retourner travailler dans un
contexte où plusieurs travailleurs ont
des craintes relatives à leur santé
c'est clair que ces mesures de soutien
la d16 tout incite les gens à ne pas
nécessairement à retourner au travail
aussi rapidement ou avec le même
enthousiasme et qu'elle le ferait
autrement très bien très intéressant
merci monsieur giraud ont fait plaisir